music is a great way to pass the time  and thankfully we have a musician with  us right now to help lift our spirits  for a return  performance it's nate tienebag good  morning nate i don't know if i'd go with  musician but thank you so much i've  played the flute since i was in fifth  grade  and i wanted to give a shout out here to  our state song and hopefully we'll have  the lyrics on the screen for you  sing along at home  [Applause]  blue  [Applause]  yay  be  [Music]  all right home means nevada  and if it does meet home as governor  sislek says please  stay home for nevada stay home for  nevada that's the little twist we're  putting it out these days  yeah beautiful stuff nate thank you very  much